bonjour denis villeneuve bonjour la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vus c'était
avant la projection officielle des
sicarios vous était très nerveux quel
est le feeling qui domine maintenant
mais j'étais nerveux moi j'étais
considère qu' il y avait un cerveau
hésité mais on était confiant dans le
film c'est que justice qui me rassure
c'est que je savais que mes acteurs a
dors et donc aussi que les gens avec le
temps mais avec toi sont prêts à le
défendre
je ressentais enterrait plus onéreux
j'étais nerveux
par contre parce que ici la presse la
presse est en national avant les
meilleurs films du monde donc ils ont
des attentes sont très fortes
donc on peut se faire huer à cannes on
peut se faire siffler ou souvent les en
général les films sont accueillis par un
silence un silence lourd on sait pas le
film a été applaudi par la presse
et ça c'est énorme ça pour moi je
m'attendais pas à ça donc à partir de ce
moment là qu'on a su que l'accueil a été
favorable
puis les premières critiques ont
commencé à sortir principalement des
états unis jugé meilleur que tu que j'ai
une belle vie alors on est mal la
journée a bien démarré on a commencé à
relaxer par la suite on a eu un bel
accueil par le public une ovation en
soirée là encore moi j'ai un site ad
projection à cannes où les lumières
s'allument plier 50% de la qualité était
sorti pendant le film où les gens
peuvent hurler de hurler que tout vienne
faire de la merde ou six heures le
public
dray entend saisir et chose de chouette
là parce que s'ils vivent les autres
c'est que les gens réagissent
le site donc l'ovation
c'était pour moi ça a été pour moi ça
valait tous les prix il ya aussi des
critiques comme libération par exemple à
ses assassins
je suis pas la libération mais je suis
le monde et il faut dire les choses
moi j'ai jamais fait l'unanimité en
france c'est la vérité j'ai toujours une
partie
l'habitude du figaro libération sasp et
libération gpo lui mais le monde et les
cahiers de simon ne m'ont jamais et je
ne pense pas qu'un jour ils vont m'aimer
je sors c'est à dire toujours en france
souvent la critique se polarise quand un
côté m le film aux côtés de paul les
mais ça arrive parfois que des films
font l'unanimité comme momies mais
ceux-ci exceptionnel honnêtement ça
arrive très rarement par mois déjà que
les fumeurs soit bien accueilli par une
partie de la critique française c'est
déjà ça j'aurais pu me faire traîner
dans la boue par tout le monde ça c'est
la vérité
alors déjà que le film se prépare quand
même 75% la critique qui m'ont donné
jusqu'à maintenant des critiques positif
enfin que 34 ans les occupent ces
derniers comme chose comme 80 % fait
reste quand même pas pire est ce que
vous allez rester jusqu'à dimanche au
kazoo je ne sais pas encore la vérité
j'ai pas d'attentes par rapport à ça
c'est pour moi c'est déjà sincèrement le
fait que le film soit en sélectionnant
compétition c'est déjà énorme
c'est un film c'est un genre de film à
suspense un film noir qui en fait aussi
s'approche un peu de mini films de
guerre
ces films sont souvent de seulement
invité en compétition c'est
et je suis conscient qu'un palme d'or sa
femme souvent qui amène un certain état
de grâce à certaines humanisme monfils a
filmé un peu plus brutale je m'attend
j'ai pas d'attendre j'ai zéro attentes
qui pour les prix d'interprétation
vinicio déjà gagné en plus de faire
présentation à cannes dans le passé donc
je ferai comme je sais que kate
blanchett a fait quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel cette année donc c'est son
nom je suis assez serein par rapport à
ce jour je sais pas quand je vais
repartir j'attendais devraient discuter
présentement ça se discute et ce qu'ils
pensent ce qu'ils parlent pas le voir
vous avez dit que le fait d'être à
cannes c'était déjà énorme
est ce que vous sentez déjà les faits
quand est ce que vous sentez qu'il y
aura un avant et un après pour vous dans
votre carrière
mais personnellement comme si c est pour
mosta c'est que christian savard un
grand rêve de venir ici ça fait
longtemps je pense que tous les
cinéastes du monde rêvent d'aller à
cannes ou aller au zoo score je sais pas
pourquoi ça fait partie de notre image
dans qu'on est jeunes cinéastes ont des
enfants fait partie de dés des grands
privilèges puis c'est pour moi je sais
pas comme dans ma carrière je sais pas
mais en tout cas dans mon coeur oui ça
fait ça me touche beaucoup de si il ya
une nouvelle génération de cinéastes
québécois qui s'exporte qui
marche bien à l'étranger après denys
arcand qu'un peu ouvert le chemin pour
tout le monde
emily blunt en conférence de presse à
parler de la rivalité entre vous jean
marc vallée et xavier dolan peut-on et à
l'étranger aussi
est ce que c'est vrai qu'une rivalité
entre ce que yo définitivement grande
amitié
jean marc et moi et avec xavier aussi
et de l'admiration aussi et gagne
nécessairement la compétition des
réalisateurs des narcissiques t'es sûr
que des rapports de compétition c'est
sur le jeu compétitif dit que mais je
dirais pas que c'est une rivalité c'est
ce qu'on s'amuse avec ça il ya de
l'émulation
la séance que la stimulation moi je
désir de voir moi je pense que ce que
vous aviez jean-marc fonds oddo cie
d'art québécois aussi équipements qui
vont stimuler à travers les années c'est
tellement riche de sentir
l'effervescence cinéma québécois comme
ça moi je me semble définitivement un
cinéaste qui est plus près de l'amérique
vous aviez définitivement si gasquet qui
est plus proche de la france jean marc
et de mon côté même si un peu bien que
plusieurs au québec comme sébastien
pilote efficient fournier francis la
claque va retourner bientôt j'espère
philippe falardeau aussi des gens qui
ont maxime giroux qui ont énormément de
talent ça c'est très stimulant pour moi
de sentir que ça ça me pousse pousse à
cesser de faire mieux tout le temps une
polémique à cannes depuis le début du
festival que beaucoup au sujet de ces
réalisateurs étrangers qui tourne en
anglais des gens qui disent que c'est
une tendance inquiétante parce qu'il ya
des spécificités qui se perd un petit
peu c'est à dire que 1,6 cariou c'est
pas un film québécois non plus film sur
l'anti nos par exemple yutz et plus un
film italien est ce que cette polémique
là est justifié de prévost j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu la finition sinon je ne sais
pas si ça a affecté son style sa voix
tant que là c'est un cas que l'essence
d'un sénat se perd pas
moi je sens qu'il ya eu faute à mon chum
quelques incendies qui est étonnant
partie en arabe en passant ou que
commencera la limite raciste moi ce que
je trouve rien qui a tancé si j'étais
affecté je pense que c'est une
coïncidence je pense pas que ça va t'en
sais que c'est une tendance lourde je
pense que mais s'est dit beaucoup de
choses douces et sur le marché du film
comment les fume s'exporte
comment c'est difficile pour le cinéma
d'auteur de s'exporter aujourd'hui car
pendant dans la langue de shakespeare de
dire ça je sais que tourner en france et
c'est face à saint-affrique voyage - moi
c'est pas quelque chose qui m'a empêché
de tourner en français c'est que je vais
retourner en français et de toute façon
si j'écris je vais écrire en français
donc je serai présentement les scénarios
qui nous plaisent des histoires que cinq
minimes
j'ai envie de raconter sont des
histoires qui demandent des budgets qui
demande des ressources qu'il faut que je
tourne en anglais puis
pour moi je me sens pas que je m
investis parce que je sens que je
respecte mon regard et et est intacte
villeneuve bonjour la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus c'était avant la
projection officielle de sicario était
très nerveux quel est le feeling qui
domine maintenant mais j'étais nerveux
mais j'étais con c'est à dire qu' il y
avait des revisité mais on était
confiant dans le film c'est que justice
qui me rassure c'est que je savais que
mes acteurs adoré donc parce que les
gens avec quelques temps mais avec toi
sont prêts à le défendre
je ressentais un intérêt plus seuls et
isolés j'étais nerveux par contre parce
que ici la presse la presse
internationale avoir avoir les meilleurs
films du monde
donc ils ont des attentes sont très
fortes donc on peut se faire huer à
cannes on peut se faire siffler ou
souvent en général les primes sont
accueillis par un silence un silence où
le film a été applaudi par la presse
et ça c'est énorme ça pour moi c'est je
m'attendais pas à ça j'ai donc à partir
de ce moment là qu'on a su que l'accueil
était était favorable puis les premières
critiques ont commencé à sortir
principalement des états unis faisait
meilleure critique j'ai une belle vie
alors honnêtement de la journée a bien
démarré on a commencé à relaxer par la
suite on a eu un bel accueil par le
public une ovation
en soirée là encore moi j'ai assisté à
des projections à cannes où les lumières
s'allument plier 50% de la salle était
sorti pendant le film où les gens
peuvent hurler à hurler que toi tu viens
de faire de la merde ou saisir public
dray entend saisir et chose de chouette
là parce que c'est vivant les autres
c'est que les gens réagissent tu le sais
tu as donc l'ovation ça nous a beaucoup
émus
c'était pour moi ça s'arrêtait pour moi
ça valait tous les prix il ya aussi des
critiques comme libération par exemple à
ses assassins
je suis pas à libération mais je suis le
monde et il faut dire les choses
moi j'ai jamais fait l'unanimité en
france
ça c'est la vérité j'ai toujours une
partie
d'habitude figaro libération sasp et
libération gpo lui mais le monde et les
caïds simon ne m'ont jamais et je ne
pense pas qu'un jour ils vont m'aimer
c'est à dire toujours en france souvent
la critique se polarise kango tm le film
no peu côté peut pas le lait mais ça
arrive parfois que des films font
l'unanimité comme momies mais ceux-ci
exceptionnelle en nettement si ça arrive
très rarement par mois déjà que que les
fumeurs soit bien accueilli par une
partie de la critique française c'est
déjà ça j'aurais pu me faire traîner
dans la boue par tout le monde ça c'est
la vérité
alors déjà que le film soit vu doubler
par ya quand même 75% la critique qui
m'ont donné jusqu'à maintenant les
critiques positif en quelque 30 ans les
aux calculs ces derniers comme chose
comme 80 % ferris quand même pas pire
est ce que vous allez rester jusqu'à
dimanche au kazoo je ne sais pas encore
la vérité j'ai pas d'attentes
apparaissent assez pour moi c'est déjà
sincèrement le fait que le film soit a
sélectionné en compétition c'est déjà
énorme
c'est un film c'est un genre de film à
suspense un film noir qui en fait aussi
sa projet de mini films de guerre du cd
films sont souvent seulement invité en
compétition c'est
et je suis conscient qu'un une palme
d'or ce film ce qui amène certains
datent grâce à certaines humanisme mon
jeu ce fut un peu plus brutale je
m'attend j'ai pas d'attendre 0 à 30 puis
pour les prix d'interprétation vinicio
déjà gagné un prix d'interprétation à
cannes mal passé donc je ferai comme je
sais que cate blanchett a fait quelque
chose d'assez exceptionnel cette année
donc c'est son nom je suis assez serein
par rapport à ça j'ai pas je sais pas
quand les gens partagent attendues
devraient discuter présentement ça se
discute et ce qu'ils parlent de ce
qu'ils pensent pouvoir
vous avez dit que le fait d'être à
cannes c'était déjà un homme est ce que
vous sentez déjà les faits quand est ce
que vous sentez qu'il y aura un avant et
un après pour vous dans votre carrière
mais personnellement comme si c est pour
moi c'est assez excitant
sincèrement un grand rêve de venir ici
ça fait longtemps je pense que tous les
cinéastes du monde rêve de l'acca
nouvelle et au zanskar je sais pas
pourquoi ça fait partie de notre
imaginaire qu'on est jeunes cinéastes
font les enfants c'est pas partie de dés
des grands prix village puis c'est pour
moi je sais pas comme dans ma carrière
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas dans mon
coeur oui ça fait ça ça me touche
beaucoup de déçus il ya une nouvelle
génération de cinéastes québécois qui
s'exporte qui est
marche bien à l'étranger après dernière
qu'un peu ouvert le chemin pour tout le
monde
emily blunt en conférence de presse à
parler de la rivalité entre vous et jean
marc vallée
il ya examen de langue peut tourner à
l'étranger aussi est ce que c'est vrai
ce qu'une rivalité lorsque you
définitivement grande amitié
jean marc et moi et avec xavier aussi et
de l'admiration aussi et gagne
nécessairement la compétition des
réalisateurs des narcisses ectif sûr que
dekker a pas de compétition c'est sûr je
suis compétitif dit que messi serait pas
si une rivalité c'est qu'on s'amuse avec
ça il ya d'émulation
la séance que la stimulation moi je
désir de voir aux jeunes ce qu'est ce
que vous aviez jean-marc fonds oddo
didace québécois aussi documents qui
constituent à travers les années
c'est tellement
riche de sentir l'effervescence du
cinéma québécois comme ça moi je me
semble définitivement c'est un cinéaste
qui est plus près de l'amérique
vous aviez définitivement c'est à ce qui
était plus proche de la france jean marc
et de mon côté aussi un peu mais y en a
plusieurs au québec comme sébastien
pilote il fit six ans fournier français
cela qui va retourner bientôt j'espère
philippe falardeau sont des gens qui ont
un maxime giroux qui ont énormément
talent ça c'est très stimulant pour moi
de sentir que ça ça me pousse ça pousse
à cesser de faire mieux tout le temps
d'une polémique à cannes depuis le début
du festival que beaucoup au sujet de ces
réalisateurs étrangers qui tourne en
anglais des gens qui disent que c'est
une tendance inquiétante parce qu'il ya
des spécificités qui se perd un petit
peu dire que 1,6 cariou c'est pas un
film québécois non plus film de
sorrentino par exemple yutz et plus
infimes italien est ce que cette
boulimique là est justifié de prévost
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu le finissant
sinon je ne sais pas si ça a affecté son
style sa voix tant que la last ranker
que l'essence d'un cinéaste parpaings
moi je sens que ce carré au trou dans
mon film que l incendie qui est étonnant
partie honorable en passant ou que
commencera la limite c'est moi ce que je
trouve inquiétant c'est si j'étais
affecté je pense que c'est une
coïncidence je pense pas que ça va te
dire qu'avec une tendance lourde je
pense que mais ça dit beaucoup de choses
aussi sur le marché du film comment les
films s'exporte
comment c'est difficile pour le cinéma
d'auteur de s'exporter aujourd'hui qu'un
candidat dans la langue de shakespeare
de dire ça je sais que tournant français
safran soit africain de voyage - moi
c'est pas quelque chose qui m'a empêché
ton en france c'est que je vais
retourner en français et de soissons si
j'écris je vais écrire en français donc
jusqu'à présentement les scénarios qui
me plaisent
j'ai envie de raconter sont des
histoires qui demandent des budgets qui
demande des ressources il faut que je
tourne en anglais puis
pour moi je me sens pas que je m
investis parce que je sens que je
respecte mon regard et est intacte